your Marvel Studios black panther
Leticia and I play brother and sister I
play to Chawla he's both a hero of
Wakanda and it's key like hair accessory
built him this incredible sea food with
all sorts of amazing tech but grow let's
be honest how clear does it look I mean
it's super cool but this fabric is made
out of my brain the suit is destructive
look yeah sure but it's got kinetic
energy absorption that means it can
absorb anything and redirect it whoa it
goes on I'm telling you you wear this
anyway let's talk about the claws shop
how you're gonna look and see if I made
you think which is it bones up in Flint
it is very nice it's pretty cool you can
see Marvel Studios black panther in
theaters this february contain scenes
that are intense and maybe inappropriate
for younger viewers I have seen God's
fly
I've seen men build weapons that I
couldn't imagine
I've never seen anything like
the black pencil is over 16
are you ready
[Applause]
[Music]
one Panther this film is not yet rated I
have seen God's fly I've never seen
anything like this
majesty how much more you hiding the
answers will come soon enough
a war he's coming
dear leader about the black pencil
now that I have your attention
Panther hey everybody now that we have
your attention we have to break down
this new Black Panther footage so
there's a couple things going on here a
bunch of news stuff we get some
confirmation about what the suit
actually does when you blast it with
energy we get that claw shot where he
just opens up on Black Panther it blasts
a hole that his suit absorbs but there's
like this empty patch here that then
later regenerates itself so he's already
got one up on Iron Man unless his new
model prime armor that he's wearing
during infinity war also regenerates
itself on command like you've only seen
him walking around on set with it fully
on and then with the arc reactor on so
we actually haven't seen everything that
the new Iron Man armor can do but they
also narrate the trailer and I love the
way that they cut these sometimes like
he's obviously one of the New Avengers
he's part of the Illuminati in the
comics so of course he's gonna be one of
the biggest a list Avengers during phase
four but you have ever Ross that sounds
like he's meeting him for the first time
in this United Nations building here
like I've seen all this crazy
Avengers level stuff because he just
came from civil war but he's seen
nothing like what he's seen in Wakanda
so this might be happening relatively
early in the film because there's been
all kinds of pictures with them in the
mountains like with him slowly pushing
their way into Wakanda in Everett Ross
just looking completely surprised at
every single turn so we know how he gets
involved with all the ulysses klaw stuff
because there's this big chase scene and
then Everett Ross is the one that's
interrogating him and you get that cloth
speech where he's like have you ever
heard of Wakanda it's the real El Dorado
the city of gold but the gold is
actually vibranium so the way they've
weaved it into the costumes and they've
actually added this to the last couple
of trailers to where you see it like
forming around them almost like it's
some sort of organic thing that just
builds itself around their faces
technically it's not organic the
necklace has all that technology built
into it like Sheree confirms like oh it
all comes out of a necklace boom how
cool is that
but it's the technology in that necklace
that tells the suit when it needs to
rebuild itself or when Black Panther
wants to form the helmet around his face
so there's a certain amount of
neurological connection that he has with
the suit and they haven't shown with
that interfaces like I'm sure they'll be
some cool offhanded line of dialogue
we're sure he's explaining how the suit
works and black panther goes through a
montage where he's just playing with all
the different functions like
holy crap I didn't know it could do all
these things but he also has a Jarvis
style AI built into the suit the same
way that Iron Man has that built into
all of his technologies the difference
in the way that they used that though
the implementation is is that he doesn't
talk to it the way that Iron Man talks
to Friday because there's this whole
anthropomorphize thing with the Iron Man
a is like he's turned Friday into this
seeming woman like a version of Pepper
Potts that he can just talk to like the
whole joke about this hot assistant that
he has an implied relationship with
except it's a digital assistant so it's
like this 50s Don Draper joke and black
panther doesn't get into any of that but
from a functional standpoint all of the
artificial intelligence of his suit
works the same way and I did a video
just a little while ago about the
prelude story that they wrote for
infinity war in how important Sheree is
for fixing the Winter Soldier because in
that story she implies that the
artificial intelligence technology that
they have is far beyond the technology
that was used to create Ultron so
imagine how advanced Ultron was mine gem
plus Jarvis equals Ultron so if Wakanda
has technology that's either on par or
even better than that and you get a
little bit of that in these big scenes
that they put into later trailers where
do they have the energy shields up the
Black Panthers jumping around and he's
using all his kinetic energy from the
suit so this is stuff that you didn't
see in the earlier trailers so there's a
whole lot of technology being used in
these big bites that we didn't know
about you may have also spotted Black
Panther in that trailer in this purplish
looking soul world speaking to what was
either the Panther gods in the tree or
maybe the spirits of his deceased
ancestors they could go full-on Panther
God because they did confirm that there
are gods in the Marvel Universe Thor
Odin's Ella they're all genuine gods so
it's not that much of a leap to assume
that the wakandans have worshipped the
Panther God for a long time our Black
Panthers tribe has worshipped the
Panther God there are other minor gods
that the other tribes of Wakanda worship
but I don't think that they're going to
get too crazy with that during the Black
Panther movie the MCU tends to simplify
a lot of that craziness so what I'm
guessing is is these will wind up being
the spirits of his ancestors that will
somehow communicate with him but I don't
think they're gonna go full-on Lion King
and just have the Panther
start literally talking to him but
because we have heard his father's voice
in the trailer speaking to him we know
that he's going to be involved in the
movie somehow the wood is changing
[Music]
you are a good man
with a good heart
and it's hot I think it'll probably just
be a voice in his head but I don't think
you're gonna see like some hilarious
moment with Panther lips moving and
speaking to him literally but let me
know in the comments if Black Panther
has a eye that's more advanced than Iron
Man's a eye and he has technology that's
more advanced than Iron Man's what other
surprises do you think there are inside
the black panther suit because that's
usually how these movies go where you
get like this new technology you get
like a new hot rod to test out like
spider-man gets his new suit he learns
about a couple cool things that it does
like oh my god I didn't know that there
was a parachute kill mode or even seat
heaters built into my new Spidey suit so
that's usually how they cut these
trailers where it's like whoo check out
this really cool new function that it
has but we're not gonna show you the
four other really badass things that it
does because it's gonna be involved in
some big final fight moment the whole
thing I'm hoping for and that big final
fight with kill monger because he's
wearing almost the exact same technology
just a slightly different version of it
is that because they're hyping up the
ability for them to give off that
kinetic damage that they absorb is that
during their fight black panther stores
so much kinetic energy because they're
just going at each other so hardcore
that he gives it all off and just
completely blasts the suit right off of
kill monger like he just gives off so
much kinetic damage that it just almost
vaporizes him without absolutely killing
him because I don't think they're gonna
get rid of Michael B Jordan anytime soon
you don't cast someone like that and
then just get rid of him right away
it's like casting Tom Hiddleston it's
low-key you're gonna bring him back at
some point and there's inevitably gonna
be at least two more Black Panther
sequels but we can talk about that in
another video so there is a new round of
that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you
have to do to enter just be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video I'll
announce a new winner when I post a new
Avengers video there is some cool pepper
potts
new Iron Man suit stuff that's going on
so I might do a video for that but leave
all your video requests in the comments
below click here for that other brand
new Super Bowl trailer they just dropped
and click here for brand new blast
thank you so much for watching everybody
said awesome I'll see you guys tonight